[Music]
delighted to talk to you today I think
we started emailing each other like
three or four years ago yeah it's been a
while it's been a couple books sure so a
long time in the making and really
excited to dig in all of this stuff with
you I think you've really hit on a nerve
here and you're doing really important
work in a world of distractions and
social media you've all know a Harare
recently said famously that clarity is
power yeah and things like solitude
focus and the deep work that you talk
about really have become superpowers but
are quickly you know without a lot of
diligence on behalf of the individual
becoming you know going the way of the
dodo
yeah well it's a more practice skill
than I think we realized mmm-hmm
concentration it just seemed like
something we all know how to do if we
all know how to focus on things it's
just a matter of where we doing it
enough and I think we're now learning
that it's a practice skill and we didn't
realize how much practice we were
actually getting doing this and how much
we get out of practice when we introduce
new technologies that can you know keep
our attention yeah I mean in my own
personal experience it's undeniable how
much more difficult it has become and
how much more diligence is required in
order to set aside the phone and focus
on the work that is actually going to
move the needle like in my own personal
life and as somebody who you know
struggles with addiction I'm in recovery
I'm just a junkie for anything that's
gonna give me that hit and it's very
difficult for me to create you know to
have the rigor and create those rules
around around youth so that it doesn't
just infect every aspect of our lives
you know in an era in which you know
boredom is now no longer required yeah
which by the way is incredibly novel I
mean it really is the first time in
human history that you can get rid of
every moment of boredom or I would say
even solitude right time alone with your
own
I mean this was completely unavoidable
throughout human history just throughout
your day you're just going to have
regular moments where it was you alone
with your own thoughts I mean so it's
just hardwired into the human experience
and it's really the last what seven
years that we've said okay let's put
billions of dollars in the smartest
minds at work at getting a sort of
worldwide high-speed wireless Internet
network and these devices in our pockets
that can tap into it at any moment and
all these algorithms behind it that can
get us the perfect bit of distraction at
any any moment that we need it and so we
can for the first time in human history
actually banish all boredom and all
solitude from our lives so it's like a
wild experiment a radical experiment but
I think the results are it's not going
well
mm-hmm yeah and I think we've been
presented with this choice either we
become this neo-luddite where we just
dispatch with all of it all together or
we're a denialist where we just say well
this is this is the way that it is now
and we just need to adapt as a species
and you found a different path in into
this yeah you hear this neo let I charge
a lot but I'm yet to find one so it
seems like this is often thrown right
like okay your only option is right your
denialist or you're gonna be this
neo-luddite or you'll have to say okay
I'm no neo-luddite but I can't actually
find anyone who is you're kind of a
neo-luddite well I guess so I mean I
mean somebody a peer scientist is what
you are yeah that that's what creates
this whole conundrum around this because
you actually understand and yet you know
I don't know anyone else in your age
bracket that has never had a social
media account yeah yet here you are
breathing and you're alive and you look
healthy and happy yeah I have a couple
friends seem to be functioning you know
you want any the proof is in the pudding
like not how many books have you written
six books right yeah yeah that's what
that's why I tell my my publicist
sometimes like okay maybe we could sell
a little bit more copies of this book if
I was active on social media but I'd
probably have written 20% less total
books so well you've made the New York
Times bestseller list like you've
demonstrated that you can achieve these
Heights in an era in which we've been
told you know it's required that you
have these accounts and this presence in
the digit
space in order to move the needle on
sales in an analogue world well I mean I
think something that's going on here and
I think Foods a good analogy right so so
in food we're used to this idea that you
might say something like I don't eat
this type of food I don't think it's I
don't think it's good for me right I
mean obviously this is a message you've
taught written a lot about and no one
comes back and says you know well rich
role is a sort of anti food guy he's not
in the eating nutrition right we're used
to it and the idea of food that there's
there's different qualities you get
different results out of it and so I'm a
tech guy I mean I'm a computer scientist
I'm an Internet nerd I was using the net
before you know there was world wide web
browsers I've been blogging for over a
decade and so I look at certain things
like social media platforms and to me
it's junk food and so I don't see it as
a stance of you know neo-luddism to say
for example I don't use Facebook I see
it more like saying I don't eat Doritos
mm-hmm and that you can you can love
tech like I do but not necessarily
embrace all of the trends and so that's
a lot of the message I'm out there out
there preaching is that you have to be
intentional you have to be selective you
know how do you counter the argument
that you know just leveraging my own
personal experience like I I'm totally
on board with everything you're saying
and yet I can't deny that social media
has benefited me in certain ways like it
is created the foundation upon which
I've created my career in many ways and
it's allowed me to connect with and
contact a lot of interesting people that
are now like friends of mine and you
know in my inner ear IRL in my real life
yeah well I mean this is part of the
issue when you're talking about things
like social media is that in some sense
the the people from whom you might be
hearing about these topics is actually a
pretty rarified group right so so it's
people that maybe have large media
brands right I mean so this is core
perhaps to your business you you have a
sort of a large brand and a lot of
businesses use social media very
successfully there's a reason why
Facebook is worth five hundred billion
dollars you know for example if you're
trying to advertise it's like a miracle
what right what Facebook allows you to
do but I don't know that circumstance
applies to most people mm-hmm right I
mean so for a lot of people I mean
they're they're trying to whatever
they're trying to connect more with
their families our community they're
trying to do well by their
do well by their job they're trying to
build a life that it has certain
elements of meaning to it they maybe
don't need or have any reason to have a
large audience and yet they still feel
compelled well I think I just need to
vaguely be on these services mm-hmm and
then they step back and look at what's
going on and they realize it's one two
three hours a day that they're they're
glancing at these things so at the core
minimalism for example is this notion of
there's no good or bad tech but
intentions are really useful yeah I look
at it along two different spectrums one
is creation versus consumption like are
you using the platform to create
something to put something out in the
world versus just scrolling to see what
everyone else is doing and then the
other thing that you explore pretty
deeply in your book is this idea of
utility versus autonomy yeah so can you
explain that well that's what I noticed
right I mean so when I was looking into
this issue I was trying to understand
why people were feeling this creeping
unease right and why that had changed
what was in the last few years that have
made people increasingly uneasy about
their technological lives and you talk
to people it's really not usefulness
right it's not oh this tech is useless
and I hate spending time on it in fact
if you're using one of these apps for
some reason while you're doing it
there's some reason why you download it
there's some value you get so people's
complaint was not this is useless it was
more about autonomy so people worry that
they're using it too much
that's what I was picking out that
they're looking at the screen instead of
doing things they know are more
important they're looking at this screen
sort of way too much more than they know
is healthy and so it's the sense that
they're losing control over how am i
spending my time what am i trying to get
out of it right you know I used to this
is the push back I used to get so so
I've been sort of a public critic of
some aspect of social media for a long
time and before about two years ago I
used to get much more ferocious pushback
when I would like say write an article
in the New York Times or something
saying something critical no social
media and that really has actually
shifted a big time which is interesting
but back when I used to get the really
aggressive pushback the core of the
argument was always a usefulness
argument right so they would say well
wait a second
here is something useful that you can do
with Facebook so you need to stop
complaining about people looking at
their phones too much right that was the
argument it's this binary thing you
it's completely useless or there's some
use and if there's some use you have to
stop complaining about and and so that's
what I used to get pushed back at a lot
but people that's not the the core of
people's issues today I mean they know
there's something useful with this but
what they're worried about is doing this
an hour a day two hours a day three
hours a day when they know there's
things that are more important yeah I
mean I find myself doing that and just
powerless to stop yeah you know and and
I know I know you know I'm a I'm a
junkie so perhaps that reaction is a
little more pronounced than it would be
in the average person but it really is
difficult to put that thing down and
that's somewhat by design I mean to me
one of the more interesting things I
uncovered is that we've become used to
the constant companion model of the
phone or you just have it with you all
the time you look at it all the time we
think of that as just being fundamental
to the technology I mean that's I use a
smartphone it's there for you to have a
companion and all the time you can look
at it get information get entertainment
or what have you but it's actually much
more contrived than we realize and it
was really the social media companies
that led that charge and so maybe about
six or seven years ago maybe eight
depending on how you do the calculus
there is this moment when if your
Facebook and Facebook was that's one of
the oldest largest venture backed
companies here so they really led the
way here they're saying we have to get
our revenues numbers up right I mean
they're the IPO looming their investors
needed 100x return so they got serious
how are going to get our revenues
numbers up and what they came up with
was this radical re-engineering of the
social media experience and so they
reengineering
I post information about myself my
friends post information about
themselves and we sort of look at what
each other is up to they reengineering
it away from that and towards this
stream of incoming social approval
indicators mm-hmm and so the like button
which seems fundamental was actually a
late arrival the social media reading
into this in the book it was a late
arrival and it was a boon for their
bottom line because now the dynamic has
changed I post something now if I go
back to my app I can see if it got likes
right and maybe it got a lot of likes
but maybe got none but then a little bit
later it gets more maybe this thing gets
more likes and maybe I've been tagged in
some people's photos and and maybe I've
been favorited on Instagram and this was
actually a radical reengineering of the
experience so is less about posting
things and seeing what other people
posted and more about receiving the
stream throughout the day of social
approval indicators
indications that other people were
thinking about you
now this exploits psychological
vulnerabilities in our mind it makes it
almost impossible to not go back and hit
that app one more time and that was
purposeful and that was also the
foundation of the constant companion
model of smartphone use that's what
really changed the way we thought about
smartphones from something that you use
as a tool like oh I need directions I
have this wonderful tool I can bring it
out and get directions can be very
useful into something that you looked at
all the time so it's large it's not
fundamental right I mean it was largely
invented by a small number of companies
right and you you talk about this in the
book when you track back to Steve Jobs
as initial keynote when they launched
the iPhone which you know I I guess this
is why memory is so unreliable because I
would have thought at that time Steve
Jobs would have had a comprehensive
global vision of what's actually
happening today but in fact and what you
point out is that his whole thing was
like this is an iPod where the killer
app is to actually make phone calls yeah
I mean you didn't have to have two
devices in your pocket that was the
major seller but I went and talked to
one of the development leads from the
original iPhone to confirm all of this
he said yeah job saw this thing as a
knife and iPod they made calls but Jobs
was a minimalist right so he was all
about let's take things that are really
valuable to people and then make that
experience even better and so music was
something people really cared about I
mean people were listening to iPods all
the time jobs really really was into
music I thought music was very important
and so he wanted to make the music plane
experience better which is what he
actually spends a lot of that keynote
talking about is showing these new
features look you can swipe through this
was the first touchscreen iPod you can
swipe through the album covers look how
nice this is
and people cared about making phone
calls and and he thought it was
egregious how clumsy the existing phone
interfaces were on cell phones he said I
can make making a phone call into this
more elegant experience I can combine
these into one device it was a very
minimalist idea let me take two things
that people really like to do and then
make the experience aesthetically even
more beautiful there's no app store he
didn't trust the idea of third party
people developing apps for you know the
quality of experience was the whole
thing he told he told this lead
developer the quote that he gave me was
you know if someone else puts their app
on here
it's gonna crash the phone just when
that person needs to call 9-1-1 that was
the the fire he had and so this notion
that it was something that you would
look at a lot was not on his radar the
idea that it was even gonna be heavily
used for certain internet style
communications he doesn't get to that
and tell about thirty five minutes into
the keynote
yeah the first thirty minutes his phone
and an iPod features which is not to say
that technology shown it evolved but
it's also just to help underscore this
idea that the smartphone wasn't
fundamentally something that was meant
to be a constant companion that's
actually more an instantiation of a
small number of social media companies
business models than it is some sort of
emergent phenomenon that as this
technology came along that we all
decided that this was a better way to
use it
well this turning of the tide against
Silicon Valley and this you know brewing
distrust that we now have about the
motives and the intentions of these
oligarch founders was really initiated
in many ways by the work of Tristen
Harris and him kind of going on sixty
minutes and that's really how you open
the book here by setting the stage about
what's really going on so we can really
understand the gravity of what these
apps you know represent in terms of
hijacking our precious time and
attention yeah well I mean he was a
whistleblowers the best way to
understand it I mean he had he had
trained to figure out how do you capture
and manipulate people's attention with
applications he studied in BJ Foggs lab
at Stanford persuasive technology then
he had a start-up the startup was
acquired by Google and they got very
aggressive about using the technology to
help capture eyeballs and make things
more sticky and interest on did this
sort of Cameron Crowe Jerry Maguire type
moment where he wrote a manifesto
it was essentially like we need to we
need to protect our users attention
right I mean it was like right out Jerry
Maguire like this isn't good like we're
or we're exploiting you know our users
we're exploiting their attention
returning the gadgets and this thing
gets passed around Google gets passed up
the Larry Page like okay we're gonna
make you the whatever it was
Czar of ethics or something like this
and and did nothing happen
mmm-hmm because there's just billions of
dollars at stake so he left and said
okay I'm gonna try to spread the
word and he was on sixty minutes and he
was being interviewed by Anderson Cooper
and he pulled out this this the
smartphone and said this thing's a slot
machine in your pocket and I think that
was sort of that was the moment that was
the moment you know yeah and it's one of
those things where everybody who saw
that despite whatever pushback was
happening at the time like we all
intuitively know it know it to be true
yeah so it struck a chord and it really
resonated with a lot of people but what
Tristan did which I think is important
is I mean up to that point a lot of
people thought about this being as a
slot machine from a perspective of lack
of personal willpower control like I
look at this thing too much it's just me
being lazy and what Tristan was saying
is no no no this is engineered to get
that effect I mean he was to be one of
the first people to say hey we've been
borrowing ideas in Silicon Valley from
Las Vegas casino gambling where they
figured out once they went to digital
slot machines you could actually
hard-code in the reinforcement schedules
right what was digital you could exactly
figure out at what rate you got
different awards and the slot machines
right what's right back when it was
analog was a little bit more random and
so back when they made that transition
in Las Vegas they did a lot of studies
to figure out what's the reward schedule
on the slot machine that's going to keep
you holding the handle and this stuff is
published and so they're looking at that
research in Silicon Valley when they're
trying to think about except for now
instead of it being triple cherries it's
it's 20 likes versus five likes uh-huh
but they were studying these same ideas
and putting these into play so you had
this thing that you hit and it would
just be like a slot machine handle pool
so what Tristan was saying is like look
when I say this is like a slot machine
I'm not just being hyperbolic or
metaphorical I mean we're literally
engineering this thing to be like a slot
machine you're not just lazy the reason
why you're looking at this thing so much
is that we have people who are very
smart
we're figured out how to make that
happen they're subtle too and their
nefarious like one thing that always
gets me on instagram is when I open up
Instagram and you'll see a quick flash
of a photo and then it disappears to
update it to the newest one and I'm like
wait what was that one and I'll scroll
until I get to that it's like that is
insane yeah you know yeah well I mean
there's so many subtle things right like
the fact that when Facebook first was
going mobile they're working on the
graphics mhm and so one of the graph
they needed for the app was a little
icon that said you have updates and so
the graphic designer is there good
graphic designer so here's the Facebook
palette it's grays and blues and we have
this nice Update button and the
attention engineer said no no forget the
palette it has to be alarm red right you
get 2x2 more clicks right because our
brain I brain can't ignore it or this
this innocent feature on Twitter where
you you pull down the stretch it down
and then release and then it updates ya
the Twitter thing yeah right there's
really no reason to have that but it
gives you a slot-machine handle effect
where that's right if it just was kind
of updating you kind of see what's going
on it doesn't really feel like you're
pulling the handle a lot so subtle so
both Tristan and then someone else NYU
professor Adam alter have claimed that
Facebook and Instagram also were
supposedly doing artificial holding back
of likes and favorites so they can make
it more intermittent because we know
this from behavioral psychology if you
sometimes get the reward you sometimes
don't it short-circuits the dopamine
system in a way that gets you to go back
much more than you should that's why the
pigeons will Peck forever if they
sometimes get the pellets and and then
sometimes don't and so there's been
accusations that they started
artificially batching likes and
favorites so that you would sometimes
seem and sometimes not because if it was
a steady stream it's not nearly as
compulsive right as like I almost had
the cherries but then it get the last
one and then this time I got right so
now you can check your Facebook then you
check your Twitter then you check your
Instagram then you go to slack or
whatever and your email and then you
just go back to the beginning again it's
like yeah and we wonder why like the non
industrial productivity metrics in the
American economy have been stagnate over
the last ten years right well let's talk
about that so the sense is or the idea
behind all of this is that these tools
make us more productive members of
society so myth or fact well which tools
are we talking about well let's talk
about let's talk about things that
really are designed to enhance
productivity like email yeah and slack
and you know these these technological
innovations that are supposed to create
seamless workflow yeah so the problem
with with email and slack and this was
really at the core of my last book so
not digital minimalism but but deep work
right what was this notion that as
knowledge economy in particular so let's
just look at knowledge work and as you
get past the entry-level
knowledge work is really built on
concentration because what you have to
do literally speaking is taking
information think about it produce new
information that has value right I mean
that's the that's the grist mill of
knowledge work so you introduce
something like email and it seems like a
no-brainer like we we write memos it
takes a long time if we can do it
electronically just has massive
advantages it's cheaper it's faster it's
more stable I can access it when I'm
away from the mail we don't need a whole
mailroom right there it just seems like
there's all these advantages to it but
there's unexpected consequences and in
particular what happened is once we
introduced things like email it shifted
the way we worked and so subtly our
workflow shifted to something that I
call the hyperactive hivemind which is
let's have a constantly ongoing
unstructured conversation so let's have
a lot of knowledge work now unfolds you
can use slack or email or whatever tool
SMS is now integrating the office a lot
more where we can just anyone can reach
anyone at any time so it's like we have
this ongoing unstructured conversation
which wasn't possible before but this
technology makes possible its it's not
an unnatural thing to do it's basically
how you know we would coordinate if we
were in like a small group of Peel with
the hunters we would just sort of have
an unstructured conversation you go that
way I'll go this way
we just scaled it up the large
organizations by using these tools the
problem is if you have to tend this
ongoing unstructured conversation it
forces you to have to keep changing your
attention back to the communication
tools and then back to the thing that
you're actually trying to produce value
on then back to the communication tools
you have the context switch a lot and
the psychology literature tells us that
that context switching just completely
reduces our cognitive capacity makes it
very difficult for us to actually
concentrate and produce value with our
brain so it was an inadvertent
externality but by introducing these
low-friction communication tools it
changed the way we worked it made things
much more convenient but by doing that
we actually got much worse at the core
business of knowledge work which
requires conversation producing value
and so this is why I think our
productivity metrics have been stagnant
for over a decade is even though the
tech has gotten more advanced we have
fragment that our attention to the
degree that we're actually really bad at
the core thing to
we need to do which is actually sitting
there and writing the legal brief right
or the article or the market we put that
at the bottom of the list instead of the
top and we're so easily I think just by
way of how we're wired and how we've
evolved that when there's an incoming
message even if you don't have
notification setup there's that pull
like I need to attend to that because
you know my standing within the tribe is
dependent on how you know immersed I am
in that yea munication flow to be
dangerous right if you're in the tribe
and and someone's tapping you on the
shoulder you know I'm gonna ignore you
alright you need a spear in the back
we're wired for that but we don't know
that we see that there's a email waiting
for us in the inbox that deep part of
our brain doesn't see that any different
then there's the guy with the spear
right as you know how to prioritize yeah
our brain deal with all these our brain
is not meant to have a thousand emails
in an inbox each of which needs an
answer to them it's just it's
short-circuiting an ancient instinct of
sociality and we have these ancient
social instincts that have been built
into our brain through evolution over
millenia it's very complicated large
portions of our neuronal hardware is
dedicated towards the subtle act of how
do you manage communication among groups
how do you manage social dynamics how do
you keep your tribe together if you
start messing around with it with
technology you know I say well what's
just let's let's take the tribal
conversation but now it's a thousand
people within the company or now you
have a hundred thousand fans you're also
trying to read you through these thing
means or let's get social media which is
you know twenty Roald's and hooded
sweatshirts just hacking with sociality
and some incubator somewhere let's
completely change social interaction but
we have this hardware that's been
evolved to do it one way of course we're
gonna have unexpected consequences I
mean we shouldn't be surprised it's just
like when we started messing around with
food with industrial and processed food
in the mid twentieth century
everyone got unhealthy because our
bodies had evolved for thousands of
years to expect very specific things out
of food it didn't know about high
fructose corn syrup and so we shouldn't
be surprised when we got an obesity
epidemic I think the same things going
on with our social cognitive lives right
now yeah I mean I walk around with a low
grade anxiety all the time because I
know there's so many like sort of
tended to incoming messages coming at me
I thought I can't possibly respond to
all of them and you know for years there
was this movement of inbox ERL like
here's all the hacks you can you know
get at the bottom of here and now it's
just well forget about that like here's
how you can be sort of calm and content
yeah when you know thousands of
unattended to email messages yeah I mean
the funny thing about inbox zero is that
the guy who came up with the concept and
gave the famous Google Talk Merlin man
got a book deal
to write a book this was years ago write
a book on inbox zero because he had
given this famous talk that was you
could find online I think at Google
about here's how you process your inbox
and you get it down to zero or whatever
so you got the book deal and eventually
the book deal fell through he couldn't
write the book because at some point he
realized it's not about getting the
inbox down to zero right actually that's
the wrong game he was like I can't in
good conscience write this book and and
the the book deal fell away because he
had this epiphany like oh wait a second
this isn't the right game the right game
is not okay how do I stay on top of this
like mountain mountain of communication
the right game is how do I produce good
things yeah at the core of of everything
you do is an appreciation and a respect
for you know what you call deep work the
immersive experience of of doing really
what you're here to do whatever it is
that your focus is and whether that's
you know as a member of a large
organization a corporation or writing a
book or you know whatever the case may
be and appreciating the extent to which
these externalities aren't just
jeopardizing or threatening our ability
to do our best work but appreciating the
extent to which they're constantly
degrading it and you know built into
that is an understanding like like we
tend to I guess what I'm getting at is
we tend to think like hey what's the big
deal I'm gonna take a break and answer a
few emails and go back to the work but
it's really understanding that when you
do that that you know making that
cognitive switch there's a huge cost
that gets paid to try to get ramped up
again so that you can become in that
immersive State of Mind yeah
well that cost I think is one of the the
big underemphasized storylines at the
intersection of psychology and workplace
productivity because we have this
movement
in the late 90s early 2000s where people
begin to realize that pure multitasking
didn't work right because we had this
remember that was a big deal and that
when we first got personal computers in
the office people like yeah I'm on the
phone while doing email and typing the
the memo and yeah I could do three
things at the same time and it didn't
take long some good research came out
that said no of course that doesn't work
you're just switching between all the
things and doing them all pretty bad and
so then people said great I'm a single
Tasker now right and I'm only doing one
thing at a time but what they weren't
factoring in was this context switching
cost because you're saying hey I'm not
multitasking because I only have one
thing open sure every 10 minutes I maybe
jump over right to the Gmail tab but
just for like a minute and then I come
back to this thing so I'm not doing two
things at the same time and so it felt
like you were being productive but what
we didn't realize is there's this
context switching cost so it's called
the tension residue but essentially when
you leave your primary tasks go to an
email inbox you see all those messages
most of which you can't answer right now
and the Paleolithic Minds getting
worried you know it's almost half of me
at the fire and then you go back to
let's say the main thing you're doing
which is like right you know the Aubry
for whatever there's a residue left from
that switch which reduces your cognitive
capacity and it takes a long time to
clear out I mean it's easy to test in
the lab you have people do puzzles that
you can quantitatively measure and then
you distract them for one minute what
they do is they say oh we forgot the you
forgot to fill out this paper on the
form right and then they go back to the
puzzles you just you watch the
performance drop and it takes a while
till until it comes back up and so
what's happening is in the standard
knowledge work situation even when
people are elite level knowledge works
they're creative workers they think
they're single tasking they do these
quick checks frequently enough that they
never leave that state of attention
residue so now it's like we're all
taking a reverse no atrophic that makes
us dumber uh-huh and we don't recognize
it right and this is why the people who
prioritize really unbroken
concentrations seem like they have a
superpower it's essentially just
relative to everyone else which is in
the state of self-imposed attention
residue which is keeping their cognitive
performance artificially low mm-hmm yeah
today if you can just be somebody who
can carve out even two hours a day
undistracted focused attention you
really are like a superhero yeah yes
that would just be the norm even 30
years ago
ago you've seen all these industries
I've noticed it with book editors right
that that email came along right because
book editing is a great example I think
because it hasn't changed much at least
what the ultimate goal is the last
hundred years you're a book editor you
have writers who writing books that
you're helping to edit and bring in the
fruition right I mean it's the the end
result is the same now that it was 50
years ago a hardcover book except for
you've seen this shift in the post email
age for basically book editors to all
their editing at home mm-hmm they've
lost the entire entire work during that
yeah its meetings in email yeah I mean
and so how can that how can that
possibly how could they possibly be more
effective at and if they've now they've
taken this core idea of working with the
book and making it better and now it
happens sort of at night or maybe early
and early in the morning so all they're
doing all day long is stuff that they
never had to do before
well I think that carries into you hear
this from a lot of people anybody who's
trying to do focus work they'll do it at
a ridiculously early hour yeah because
that's when the phone's not ringing and
there's not a lot of incoming messages
or very late at night and I think
writing is perhaps the best example
because of this idea of how delicate you
know deep work and focus is because
anybody who's trying to sit down and
write something knows that you know
someone knocks on their door and says
hey you got a minute yeah when that
exchange is over with it takes a good
half an hour or maybe even longer to get
back into that concentrated state again
yeah well this is why writers care so
much about their rituals is there it's
really clear they can see pages so so it
maybe it's a little bit more ambiguous
in a different knowledge work job I mean
you're always doing things you can't
directly see the impact but if you're
writing you say I only produce this many
pages today and someone knocked on the
door hey when I was out at this cabin
somewhere I produced this many pages
it's a lot easier the quantification
yeah but so then we have this other
issue though right so we have the issue
of interruptions and distractions within
knowledge work makes our brains work
worse but then we have the issue of what
happens outside of knowledge work right
what happens when you're home what
happens when you're looking at your
phone you know a dinner or whatever when
you're not at the workplace and this
also has an effect and so if outside of
work
now we're engaging with these highly
palatable sort of process
food equivalent attention engineered
social media platforms on our phone all
the time that's also hurting our
cognitive fitness so that even if the
next day when you go to work you have
the Faraday cage that's on top of the
mountain and no one can reach you you're
gonna have a harder time doing the
cognitive work because it's like you
were eating Oreos at night and then when
you get to the training camp the next
day you can't perform as well so we have
both of these forces are coming together
so like what was a late my book deep
work was really about what's happening
in the workplace it's making us worse at
this and the digital minimalism in part
is about what's happening outside of the
workplace right this is having all sorts
of negative consequences including on
our ability to focus when it comes to
yeah I'm experiencing that directly I
mean when I wrote finding ultra in 2012
it was you know it was pre a lot of this
kind of stuff and I didn't have nearly
as much coming out of my life I didn't
have that much trouble finding the time
to focus and putting in that work
required to get that book done and now
it's like a battle you know because the
phone is always there and you know I'm
doing a lot of other things that are
competing for my time and my energy but
I feel like I really have to be more
diligent than ever and create really
strict guidelines and rules around that
time and the pression of preciousness of
it in order to get anything done yeah
you know and I feel like - sorry to
interrupt you but I feel like getting
back to that earlier point that years of
being on my smartphone has made me
dumber in certain respects it's rewired
my brain where now it's harder to drop
into that state yeah
well part of the reason I've never had a
social media account is that my day job
is I'm a theoretical computer scientist
and so I have to solve theorems
essentially for a living and so I really
can feel the difference so for me I'm
really really worried but you don't know
the difference because you've never
actually been on right right but but
it's like it's like when you're doing
ultra endurance athletics right you're
really careful about what you eat and
how you sleep what you put into your
body because it's really gonna make a
difference right and so I guess you know
being a theoretician is sort of the
ultra-endurance right equivalent of
cognitive work and so a lot of
irritation is really care a lot about
this and so I had always had that aware
in a way I think that other people other
jobs that want to be quite so natural
because I'm just used to this
theoreticians worry a lot mmm
concentrating is their number one skill
I mean it's it's it's how they pay the
mortgage right and so I've always really
worried about what's going to be the
impact of these things on my ability to
concentrate because I lose that mmm you
know that's the whole thing that's like
my 95 mile-per-hour fastball right well
it's one thing for somebody like you who
deals in theoretics or somebody who's
writing a book but I thought it was
really interesting and this is how you
open digital minimalism which is with
Andrew Sullivan's kind of his not really
a manifesto what kind of a manifesto of
him saying you know as this hyperactive
you know uber blogger writer guy how
much his social media attention had
drained him of the joy of life and his
ability to be the best at what he does
which is thinking deeply about important
issues that impact politics and culture
well and it wasn't just and what he was
saying was not just like I can't do my
work he was he was worried about
humanity I mean the line was I used to
be a human being right and and that was
a big part of the transition from deep
work to digital minimalism is that I had
been talking about the impact of
technology on people's professional
lives these unintended consequences and
people kept coming up to me when I was
on tour for deep work and said maybe
that's fine but what about these
unexpected consequences of technology
outside of work and what it's doing to
our humanity actually our ability to
live a flourishing life and on the
surface that seems like it's similar
yeah it's tech having these unexpected
consequences but in a lot of cases the
dynamics are really different and so
that Sullivan piece I used to have to
open the book because that's what I was
picking up from from people when I was
on the road from deep work is the stuff
happening in the office is is is an
issue and I'm not as productively used
to be this can't be the right way to
work I mean doing emails all day there's
got to be something wrong with it
Justine but what's happening outside of
work where I'm constantly doing this
instead of other things people were just
getting this sense that their humanity
itself was being degraded right it's a
quality of life type issue right so the
solution right rather than becoming a
neo-luddite or a denialist you have this
idea of digital men
ilysm that's really routed in orienting
your digital diet around your core
values yeah so you know elaborate on
that for me right well I mean minimalism
itself is an old idea so you can go all
the way back to Marcus Aurelius and this
whole through line through the ancients
into thorough
into the voluntary simplicity movement
of the 1960s and remarry Kondo yes yes
that's Marin Klein called you the Murray
canto yeah yes exactly yeah it probably
wasn't the script described my physical
appearance or physical yeah but it is
yeah and and Thoreau echoes throughout
the book yeah yeah I like to say I'm
Marie Kondo without the book sale
numbers but but it it's a through-line
right and some minimalism itself is this
ancient idea that can apply to lots of
different things and the basic idea
behind minimalism is in many cases it's
better to focus most of your energy on a
small number of things that give you a
large amount of value as opposed to the
alternative which is maximalism which is
trying to spread your energy over
everything you can find it might give
you some value mm-hmm and so these two
things are set up this is like a
dialectic right you have minimalism and
maximalism
and so in all different parts of our
life the sages have told us minimalism
less is more is better than trying to
spread your attention widely right so
this is like when Marie Kondo says take
everything out of your closet and just
find two things that you really care
about or the spark joy or whatever is
you're saying focus on the things that
really matter don't get caught up on the
fact that well I kind of like this
t-shirt or maybe there's some value I
might get one day out of it the clutter
is costly focus on the things you really
care about so I'm just bringing
minimalism into people's digital
personal life basically right what do
you think is going on rather than you
know beyond the obvious that we're
talking about right now
that's happening culturally you know as
much in the analog world as it is in the
digital world that has made minimalism
like a thing right now like suddenly
Marie Kondo
is like a celebrity and you have Ryan
and Joshua the minimalists and their
documentary and the work that they're
doing and people are super interested in
decluttering their lives their mental
emotional and you know and physical
lives like what is
what is why is this the moment well in
American culture it's cyclical and and
often it's tied to the economy we get
these booms and busts we get these
periods of exuberance you know
everything's going well everyone the
economy is going well everyone's buying
things everyone's looking to the
purchased Irwin the happiness and then
there'll be a down cycle where people
get fed up with this and they embrace
sort of minimalist ideas and they'll be
an upcycled again and so I think we're
on one of these down cycles still where
where people are sort of fed up with
let's just exuberant ly go out and try
to acquire more things to make us happy
it probably began if you time it it
really goes back to the crash the
recession you see right around that
period that for a first stuck in the
21st century is where you begin to see
the minimalism Movement online for
example pick up right right it was right
around 2005-2006 where you get like Zen
habits and and Josh Becker and Cortney
Carver and then Josh when Ryan came
along a little bit later and then after
that you get Marie Kondo what's
different is that the the tech side of
it is new right it's the first cycle
that we've had so we're just coming out
of this period of initial exuberance
that really began with the iPhones
released in 2007 where it was all just
interesting I mean it really is a
miraculous technology I mean the iPhone
we didn't have anything like that before
and so that you could have all these
apps and it was interesting and people
are experimenting with it and let me try
things isn't this fun like it's trying
to get their arms around how to use this
technology and so when it comes to
personal tech we're having sort of one
of our first down cycles of the wireless
internet age we say okay we're done with
the exuberant experimentation this has
gone too far I'm sort of losing autonomy
now I need to step back and say that
periods over let's get a little bit more
mature about our relationship with our
tools and figure out what do I really
want to do with this going forward right
talk a little bit about the importance
of solitude so solitude is an
interesting idea
it has different definitions but the the
one that caught my attention came from
another book called lead yourself first
which was about solitude and leadership
but the definition that these guys used
which was it's actually an army officer
and a really well-known Circuit Court
Judge federal judge
so it's interesting pair of guys that
came together the right about salted
this judge actually he does he writes
his legal briefs in a
in Michigan that has no internet so
she's after my own heart
but anyways right they had this
definition of solitude and they said
it's not don't think about it having to
do with physical isolation right don't
think about you know are you alone on a
mountainside or not they said it all has
to do with what you're processing and so
their definition was freedom solitude is
freedom from input from other minds so
if you're processing something that was
generated from another mind you're not
in a state of solitude anytime you're
looking at this or any time you have the
earbuds in
unless it's music if you're listening to
something if you're reading something if
you're talking to someone it's not a
state of solitude your your brain is in
input processing mode our brain takes
very seriously the idea that okay this
input we're getting right now came from
another human being and that turns on
all sorts of different centers that
don't turn on when you're just let's say
looking around at an age right if you're
not doing that you're in solitude so you
can be in a very crowded coffee shop but
if you're just sitting there alone with
your own thoughts you're in a state of
solitude so there's nothing to do with
with physical isolation and why is it
important so it turns out it's it's
crucial for humans to have solitude on a
regular basis one is just maintenance
mode I mean it takes a lot of power for
our brain to okay all hands on deck like
we're processing you know there's
another human mind that we're processing
right now all hands on deck right we got
fire up all these systems as complicated
right like when I'm talking to you right
now one of the things my brain is doing
some of the research I got into is
something called mentalizing which means
I'm building a simulation of your brain
within my own brain so that I could then
start doing experiments in my own mind
of you know how is my rich role
simulation going to react if I say this
versus this it's incredibly complicated
it used a lot of energy right so if
you're always doing that the brain
doesn't get down cycles right so you're
gonna get anxiety other types of issues
it's also crucial for self development
and insight generation if our brain is
in processing mode it can't actually be
making sense in any sort of significant
degree of the information that is
processing and so you know someone
listening to this interview is in
processing mode if they really want to
get insights out of it what they also
then need is after they hear this
interview some time just alone with
their thoughts thinking about what they
heard
and that's when the brain makes sense of
it right and compares the insights
against their own mental schema as their
own understanding of the world figuring
out where it might apply or not fit into
their life
you also need it for personal
development you can't have insights into
what am i all about what are my values
how's my character can develop what do I
want to do going forward all of that
requires solitude your brain just has to
sit there have to think things have to
bounce off of each other like we need it
but I think a lot of people would
contend that it's a luxury right like
I'm just look man you know I got I got I
got you if you have a bunch of kids like
I got kids you know I'm going to my work
I'm trying to make money I'm trying to
get through the day like I don't have
time for solitude and that
self-reflection is the purview of you
know somebody's living a life that's not
mine yeah well see I think that's
because we've put solitude on this
pedestal and we think about the row in
his cabin
all right like what am I gonna what am I
gonna have time today to get out to my
cabin and but there's an illusion about
that as well that you talk about in the
book yeah which is a not really what he
was up to but we're no busier now than
we were 10 years ago but 10 years ago we
had lots of solitude and the reason is
is that when you have this precise
definition of solitude all you need is
freedom from input from other minds this
used to happen all the time you couldn't
avoid it it's you know there's nothing
on the radio and you're driving the work
solitude you're waiting in line at the
pharmacy it's solid you right now you
look at that person you're like what's
wrong with it that's wrong with them
right and so that's what's so unique
about this current circumstance is what
I mentioned before is now that we can
pull out this wirelessly connected
device
everywhere we can banish all those
moments of solitude so what's weird is
not the call for solitude to think
that's very very unusual is the fact
that we have banished solitude
that's what's incredibly rare in the
entire history of of sort of human
civilization is there's only like seven
or eight years old this idea that is now
possible they get rid of all solitude so
to get souls in your life is as easy as
just some of the places where you used
to have it even when you're really busy
you get it back by just not using your
phone so okay on my commute today I'm
not going to put on the the podcast for
the first 20 minutes or when I'm walking
a dog I'm not putting in the the earbuds
we're when I go to the store
I'm leaving the phone in the car right
so it's it's
stuff that you're already doing just do
some of those things without the slot
machine and the constant access to
solitude you know busting information
what's your sense of what society is
gonna look like 20 30 years from now
when a whole generation of young people
who have who have no memory of life
experience without a cell phone in their
hands a smartphone in their hands have
never really had that experience of
solitude to begin with well I mean that
generation is sort of wildly more
anxious than any other previous
generation
this is correlational but it's sort of a
hypothesis I make in the book is we take
Generation Z which is the first
generation to enter the young
adolescents with sort of ubiquitous
access to smartphones and social media
they use it a lot a lot more than we do
I mean they're constantly they really
have banished all solitude and
demographically speaking anxiety anxiety
related disorders just jumps off the
charts as soon as you get to the first
cohort that was born late enough to have
access to ubiquitous smartphones and
social media it's a jump that's
literally off the charts in in the sense
that the demographers had never seen a
jump that large before on anything they
measured from generation to generation
so it's literally off the charts and
it's probably because of what's
happening with the phones and probably
in part because this is a radical thing
to do to human mind is to banish all
solitude
so there's definitely much more anxious
which is problematic sherry Turkle at
MIT has this book reclaiming
conversation where she talks a lot about
how in the workplace now this generation
coming to the workplace is having a very
hard time just interacting because
they've done most of their communication
digitally but actually face-to-face
communication is very complicated and
nuanced and practice that's what you're
supposed to spend your adolescence doing
is sort of navigating awkward social
situations and trying to figure out how
to do it and so they're having a really
hard time doing things like sitting down
with the boss and talking to them
they're trying they're trying to keep
all the communication electronic which
which doesn't work because I mean
there's no emotional nuance and email
yeah and everyone is you have no idea I
mean if I'm seen across from you I know
if you're mad at me or not I can tell by
subtleties in your face but if you send
me an email
I don't know and so I might read it as
like you're furious at me or I might
read it as because there's no there's no
there's no nuance in it so this is
certainly a problem well forget about I
mean young people don't even email they
just do text and I just know from
dealing with a lot of young fields like
listen you need to call this person or
set a meeting and go talk to them and
sort out whatever problem you have
that's big and it's it's that is anxiety
yeah it's like no I just want to send
this text and I'll let me read the text
and I'm like this is not gonna solve
your problem but there's a fear of that
yeah that analog interaction well the
reason there's a fear is because it's
just really hard so I spent a lot of
time trying to understand the literature
on the intersection between sociality
and neuroscience and psychology
our brains are set up to do this right
the whole thing about our brains human
brains are the be these social
processing computers but it's incredibly
difficult like a face to face
conversation is an incredibly
complicated dance of all sorts of mental
systems and it's hard to overestimate
how much neuronal processing goes into
this and it's very hard and so you have
to practice it a lot it's what you're
supposed to be doing babies practice
this you're supposed to be practicing as
children your entire teenage years are
socially awkward in part because you're
practicing alright you're getting a
sense of what's appropriate what's not
how to read facial cues you you learn
about things like Olympic consonants
which is trying to actually match the
intonation and pacing of the other
person's voice because that makes it
more comfortable this is really really
practiced and so for most people by the
time to get to adulthood they have their
10,000 hours but if you don't get those
10,000 hours because he did this instead
you looked at the screen and then you
throw someone into the major league game
it's really scary because they're not
good at it you illustrate this with the
rock-paper-scissors
story in the book and you tell that yeah
I mean it turns out that you can be good
at rock-paper-scissors which you know it
seems things like a game of chance it
seems like it should be a game of chance
but if you get there there was a period
that unfortunately is no longer with us
but there was a period in which
rock-paper-scissor tournaments were a
thing and ESPN you know eight would
cover them and and I watts a bunch of
these videos but the the champions would
repeatedly win right so if you wouldn't
see this if you were a chance then the
the people who did
well tended to do well consistently in
the tournaments and there's these videos
on lines of these professional using air
quotes here rock paper scissor players
that would go do essentially pick up
matches with people on the street and
they would just win all the time right
you can get good at rock paper scissors
and it turns out what they're doing is
they're taking a lot of the things that
our brain does in social processing in
particular like mentalizing simulating
the other person's brain and they just
get really good at it and so they can
actually they really are trying to
understand like if I do this you'll do
this but you're probably thinking I'm
going to do this so I'm going to counter
that with this and they have these back
and forth and they're playing these
these mental chess matches but the tool
they're using to play these mental chess
matches are this incredibly
sophisticated social processing right
hardware that we have in our brain right
is there a conscious awareness that
they're doing that or is yeah so deeply
embedded in oh they're systemic yeah
from what I understand from the research
is they're actually they're actually
thinking through pretty systematically
and they're listening instinctively to
these these processing you know centers
in their brain but they're going back
and forth they also do things like plant
words so like the match I talked about
in the book is the I mean it's kind of
dumb they get up on a boxing ring you
know with the cards these guys and
khakis in the boxing ring but the one
guy says all right let's roll well he's
saying let's roll because he's trying to
get the semantic connection to rock in
the other player's brain right but then
the other player recognizes this right
and says he's trying to get a semantic
connection to rock so I'll be more
likely to play rock so I'm gonna play
scissors because I think he's gonna he
would then play paper but then the
original guy is assuming that he was
going to make that leap right so he's
probably play scissors so he does go to
rock and that's what he plays and he
wins does it's that particular match
that's amazing
all right so put me on a digital
minimalism protocol like how do we if if
one wants if one wants to begin this
process what does it look like what is
your program yeah so I have one I'm a
30-day thing which is a little bit
outside of my typical style right it's a
mean the idea of having like a 30-day
program is something
maybe a little bit makes it queasy it's
a little more self healthy yeah it's a
little bit more self healthy that I
normally am about what I found is that
you actually need it you need something
like it the the tips and the tricks
aren't cutting it right the forces are
so powerful that you know when I'm
experimenting with different things the
thing that seemed to actually work and
nothing shorter than this seemed to be
as effective was saying we're gonna take
30 days and you're gonna step away from
essentially any of the optional stuff in
your personal digital life right so so
not not the work stuff that's a separate
you know it's a separate debate I can't
get you how to answer in your boss's
emails I like the social media of the
online news the videogames the sort of
streaming YouTube videos 30 days you're
stepping away from all of that during
those 30 days what do you do well at
first there is a detox effect but I'm
not a big believer in digital detox is
as a standalone thing I mean it to me it
doesn't make much sense it seems like a
it's a weird sort of evolution of
detoxing from substance abuse where the
idea of a detox is is the first step
towards building a new life that doesn't
have the original sort of offending
behavior but in the digital world we
have this idea that like well you just
need to take breaks and then go back to
what you're doing before right yeah I do
think the idea of doing something hard
just because it's hard has inherent
value in it and at creating space in
between you and the behavior is
instructive and important but it has to
be followed should be the first or the
protocol that's gonna set you on a
different trajectory which kind of gets
into I mean look if you if you canvass
you know the blogosphere about how to
manage this it's all about these little
tricks and tools yeah take a break go
back greyscale your phone you know take
them off you know take these certain
apps off of your phone doesn't work I've
tried a lot of that stuff but I always
end up lapsing back yeah just doing what
I've always done well it's the same as
as fitness food and fitness right I mean
so when we got hyper palatable foods
everyone's gained unhealthy you know
obesity was rising we had a metabolic
syndrome rising everything was going up
we tried the tips and tricks right eat
better you know he eat less eat better
we put food pyramids up you know in the
school nurses they can do it a diet a
diet is sort of like a detox I do a diet
back to doing whatever yeah he great for
a month or whatever it is yeah and none
of that was really working so then you
think all right
who are the healthiest people we know so
like you're probably one of the
healthiest people I know you know how
did the healthiest people you know got
there's almost always to have a
philosophy right like it's plant-based
right you know I'm vegan or paleo or
whatever it is but it's usually
something much more consistent and
coherent than just tips right instead of
guiding principle a principles based on
their values they really believe into it
right that's what we need in digital so
I think the grayscale the like do a
digital Shabbat take a break every once
in a while that's like the grapefruit
diet and the the food pyramid
tips and tricks eat less move more not
going to get it done you actually need a
philosophy and so that's what digital
minimalism is basically like veganism
for right digital so so spell out spell
out like a typical philosophy that would
be workable in this context right okay
so this is what you develop during this
30-day process right so I call it the
declutter instead of a detox because
it's more than detoxing and so what do
you do during these 30 days right so
you're away from all this optional text
you're getting some space but you have
work to do and so the work I recommend
is in classic minimalist fashion you try
to get back in touch with well what do I
really care about what do I actually
want to spend my time doing outside of
work and you actually experiment you go
try things right you go back out you you
get books out of the library you join
things you invite people over for board
games and I you try to read um your
parents you become your parent you you
think what my grandfather do yeah on a
Saturday afternoon let me try that right
let me go build a canoe or something so
you actually are doing a hard work of
figuring out well what do I actually
value because people don't know for the
most part what do I actually care about
in my life outside of how to work
because we filled that void with the
screens then when the 30 days are over
you say okay just like Mary Kondo took
everything out of the closet and the
only thing is going back in or things
that I really care about it's the same
thing with your digital life you don't
just go back to what you're doing before
you say now that I know what I'm all
about I have this high bar which is if
I'm thinking about downloading an app or
returning to some service the question
is is this thing going to really help
one of these things I really value is it
going to give one of these things a
really big boost if so I'll let it back
in my life probably with some rules
about how I use it but I'll let it back
in if not I I'll miss out and I don't
care if it has some small value
some small convenience and so it's about
building the foundation of values that
you need to actually have a minimalist
approach to your tech so it's I want
tools to be used to really boost a small
number of things I really care about
really value and that's the whole
ballgame for me
I don't care that this has some small
benefit or some minor convenience I want
to use tech to get big wins and that's
sort of a classic minimalist approach
yeah
and in order to be able to fairly
adjudicate what those values are you do
need that clarity and that clarity can
only come with the young with the
decluttering process you need the time
and what I found so I ran this
experiment where I talked to my readers
about a year ago a little more than a
year ago so December 2017 they said is
anyone willing to do this declutter
process because I want to I want to you
know hear about it from different walks
of life and because it was a big ask I
thought I would get like a dozen readers
right to the point I was like it'll be
great like I'll go hang out with these
people no I'll be like journalistic I
can I'll hang out with my D clutters
1600 people signed up to do it right
which was a sign that okay people are
hungry
so hold let me just interject here
what's Georgetown saying at this point
cuz your professor at Georgetown you're
running this like you know side hustle
situation why are you doing experiments
on people yeah yeah they're cool with
everything well okay other life that you
have well this wasn't yeah I mean
technically speaking from like at
Georgetown perspective it wasn't an
experiment right for it to be an
experiment I would have to be having a
protocol for gathering data it was more
like I was encouraging readers hey you
should try this thing uh-huh X I'm
Kurian let me know you know here used to
sort of hear what it was like for you
and so then 1600 people signed up to do
it yeah I don't know what to works down
things but I'll actually you know what
in fairness I'm a computer scientist so
I'm a technologist but I also write
public-facing about the impact attack on
culture like I think there's a through
line there yeah and I think Georgetown's
a great place to do it because it has
this old history of studying human
flourishing but yeah so I do this right
I do this experiment people start
sending me reports and one of the things
I noticed is that there's a huge age
split so people who are old enough to
have gone
like their teenage and young adult years
without ubiquitous smartphones and
social media for them that three-day
process was a lot of rediscovering like
oh he had the things that I used to do I
remember this now is to sort of like
dusting off whatever for the young
people was terrifying because they had
never had those answers before so they
were starting from scratch and it was
like an existential void to the point
now where I actually recommend to young
people before you do the declutter maybe
spend some time for a couple months just
trying to get back in touch ahead of
time so you don't have a full-blown and
substantial crisis it'll work I mean it
really was yet people were especially
young concerning yeah about humanity and
Jeff first day without the phone I was
you know that's that's Nietzsche right
there staring Freud what am I going to
do right it's good no straitjacket yeah
yeah Wow like full-blown panic at just
not knowing what to do with yourself
yeah one young woman told me that for 10
days
she was compulsively checking the
weather app because it was the last
thing she had left on the phone that
actually like had some information like
you could click on it and you could get
new for me every hit yeah yeah so she
was like a meteorology meteorological
expert for about 10 days yeah no I read
that but then she said it faded and then
she was ok took about 10 days yeah right
yeah it faded and so I that I appreciate
it also a lot of people told me that
they you know some people kind of just
regarded the rule and said ok when this
is over I'm gonna go back to everything
and it lost a taste and so after 30 days
they're like I'm gonna put everything
back on my phone and then they go and
they click and it's and they realize how
arbitrary some of this is like well you
dislike scrolling these pictures and
hitting these whatever and then they
stopped using it right like it doesn't
take long to lose your taste for some of
this behavior and how many of the 1,600
didn't make it through the 30 days
probably a lot I mean I only heard from
whatever subset like a few hundred right
and the people who reported I didn't
make it through so I actually have some
sense of why they didn't it it seemed to
be for one or two reasons one if they
were just treating it like a peer detox
like I just want to break before going
back that was very hard to succeed use
their brain was like this is painful we
know we're going back to all this again
why bother suffering like another couple
weeks and then the other people who had
trouble were those who really didn't
take seriously the charge
figuring out what I want to do instead
if you don't have an answer you really
believe in and like this is what I
actually want to do with my time then it
just seems like arbitrary derivation
well it goes back to the philosophy yes
you right yes if you can connect it to
real values changes can be very
sustainable
uh-huh but if it's just I don't like
doing this and so I just want to do this
less and I'm just kind of committing to
not doing this you know I want to look
at the screen last because I don't know
it's kind of unfavorable I don't like
the feeling of it that's actually very
hard to sustain but if instead you're
saying I really care about X Y Z and so
I've built the digital life that really
boosts these things I care about
it's much much easier to right stick
with it one of the ways that you
illustrate this value based approach to
adoption and use of technology is
through the lens of the Amish community
which I found fascinating I didn't know
anything about this yeah so explain that
because that was really cool
yeah the Amish are the Amish are
interesting if you want to understand
why minimalism often works right like
why we why we end up happier even though
we are avoiding some things that might
bring a small amounts of value and so
the key thing about the Amish is people
often incorrectly think that they
essentially froze their technology like
maybe in the late 18th century something
like okay yeah you just didn't drive
through that part of the country I see
the buggies you see the buggies what is
going on yeah so you think that for
whatever reason that their religion must
have told them that tech reached its
peak and whatever 1790 and they're gonna
stop that's not at all actually what's
happening and if you spend time among
the Amish you'll keep seeing all these
incongruous things and so I write about
so Kevin Kelly the technologists I spent
a lot of time when he was younger
among the Lancaster County Old Order
Amish and he writes a lot about it and
he talks about for example you know you
show he has an Amish beer doesn't he has
an Amish boy and that's why he spent a
lot of time honest yeah yeah it's it's
purposeful but he talked about how weird
it is at first because you'll show up
and like an Amish kid will go by on
rollerblades and the moms are using
disposable diapers and they have solar
panels and you know I write in the book
about this Mennonite family which is you
know very related to Amish that has a
computer eyes you know $20,000
see routing machine right right out
there yeah that seems it seems to not
make sense yeah like a mishmash it's a
mishmash right so what's really going on
well it turns out that the Amish are
incredibly intentional about how they
use technology and their rule is pretty
simple the the main thing they care
about is the strength of the community
and so their rule is if a new technology
comes along we will evaluate it based
solely on whether it helps this value or
not so if it if it you know helps our
community keep it together okay but if
it hurts the community it pushes people
apart or hurts the social fabric then we
don't want to use it and they'll often
experiment right Kelly calls it the
Amish alpha geek so they'll have like
someone said great smartphones are a
thing you know or a Jedi or whatever try
it let's watch one guy go on guys like
you know go nuts so nuts and then
they'll watch it and so okay I don't
think that's a great idea that seems to
be hurting the community so we're not
going to do it or something like
disposable diapers like there is it's
not hurting the community and it seems
convenient so we will use it and so this
is why for example they can have
generators like electricity doesn't
bring into community apart but being
plugged into the power grid that was
worrisome to them because now you're
kind of connected into the utilities you
have to interact more with the outside
world it's why they use tractors but the
cars are really almost no community uses
cars and all the communities make their
own decisions they have a local council
that makes these decisions cars when
almost any Amish community tried them
what they what they found was that
people would leave that will leave the
village mm-hmm instead of visiting
people on Sunday afternoon they would go
dry places to do things are more
interesting so like cars littering yeah
Carson yeah most Amish communities have
phones but it'll be in like a communal
phone booth the when people had phones
in their house they stopped visiting
each other right so to drill it down
into into their philosophy or their
value based culture it's a
prioritization of of community and that
community connectivity is paramount it's
paramount and so so they're they're
betting that being intentional is going
to be more important than convenience
because obviously their decisions are
incredibly inconvenient and yet the old
owner Order Amish communities have
survived sort of surprisingly they have
survived I mean it's not like they're
isolate on some
somewhere right I mean it's surrounded
by eastern seaboard civilization most
young Amish girl in this room spring a
year where they go out there so it's not
like they don't know what's going on and
eat in ninety percent of them come back
yeah
eighty ninety percent come back so they
know what's going on and they know what
they're missing out and yet these these
communities survive and so to me the the
interesting conclusion there is that
intentionality is incredibly powerful
right and so you can carry that over to
your digital life and say yeah you might
lose some convenience if you know you
don't use this particular app that has a
couple of use cases that are useful but
if the reason you're not using this app
is because it's not part of your
intentional plan to make your life
better the value you're going to get out
of being so intentional it's gonna swamp
what you've lost in these minor
inconvenience right but the key thing is
having extreme clarity about what your
philosophy and your values are because
everything everything Orient's around
that if you don't have that then you're
not gonna have a clear direction about
how to manage these things and that's
the hard part
and that's why I say thirty days and
that's what you need the deep work to do
that right yes all right you gotta be
comfy for yeah because it's a vicious
cycle
but like you could do this minimalism
thing over a weekend right in theory
like why not just take a weekend and you
know Mary Kondo you can she does it in
one episode right I have to add the 30
days why do I have to add to thirty days
is because it actually takes a lot of
time to figure out yeah what are the
values yeah it takes time you meet that
time you know a back to the diet context
and there's people that do these
nutritional protocols where they have a
cheat day once a week and you know for
me just knowing like my self-awareness
is that that's not gonna work for me
because if I could you know go go off
the rails one day a week then that's
gonna be two days a week and it's gonna
be pretty much every day similarly in
the technology space you know to be able
to have that option at arm's length at
all times I think fails to address the
core issue that you're trying to get to
yeah so once that's based in values
right as opposed to just you know I
weigh less or something like this you
know if it's just like oh I want to
weigh less and so like a cheat day like
on paper or shouldn't affect out or
something like that but when you go to
values that this I think is the right
way to live right and so you have a
protocol for how people can get clarity
on on those values for themselves during
that 30-day period it's a lot of
reflection so to me it's reflection plus
experimentation so you sit and you think
and you come up with some I think this
might be what I care about and you go
out there and you experiment and you
come back and you revise and then you
should just have the confidence that
what you come up with rhiness 30 days is
not the final answer it's not going to
be etched into stone
you're allowed to keep changing this and
evolving it but at least it's enough
time to to get to something to have some
thought behind it right and then in a
very like pragmatic logical way you can
evaluate each you know app that you're
considering to downloading from the app
store against that value-based system
do you adjudicator that's going to bring
enough value to you know buffer against
whatever negative consequences it also
yeah that's right and it can be subtle
right and so something that a lot of
digital minimalists do is they always go
one step further than the binary
question of what I use they often always
add the second step of how and when I
use it and so because it can be a little
subtle so like one of the examples that
came up a lot in the book was visual
artists really depend on Instagram
because if you're a visual artist you
have to do creative you know creative
insight creative insight you have to
have a lot of exposure to do other
creative work that's the the fuel that
fuels creativity which is why it used to
be you know artists all lived in the
same small number of neighborhoods right
because that's where the galleries were
and they had to see what other people
are doing so Instagram is this big boon
for visual artists that's what I learned
because now you don't have to live in
Greenwich Village you can still see what
other people are doing and get that
creative input so when a lot of visual
artists do the minimalism procedure a
lot of them say okay Instagram
definitely passes that test for me I
really value creative output and this
really helps my creative output but if
they just stopped at the binary I use it
or not it could also become a crutch
they're using this thing on their phone
all the time and maybe it actually gonna
take the time away from from doing the
work and so like what a lot of the
visual artists I talked to did is after
deciding to use Instagram they said well
what's the the how and win and almost
always the answer was there's no reason
for it to be in my phone that just
serves the stock price of the company
it's financed on my computer and I'll
carefully cure
who I follow like these ten artists are
particularly influential and they often
have some sort of schedule like I go on
Sunday and I see like what they've been
doing and it takes about 20 minutes yeah
and so it's that sort of intentionality
and you can put a little bit of
structures or rules around it then you
really start to get big wins out of the
tech yeah I like that I mean I think the
pernicious delusion is that you know
whether you're an artist or whatever it
is that you're into that we use these
apps and we use our you know digital
diet in a way that we delude ourselves
into believing is actually moving us
forward but is actually just
procrastination from doing the actual
thing like I've had days where I sat for
five hours and done emails gone through
all this stuff which I suppose on some
level has some value and then it is like
that junk food thing I'll go to bed that
night I think I don't even know what I
did all day like I feel like I just
wasted the entire day and then the next
day there's just a million more emails
yeah to deal with well that's women and
there's that built-in like little
dopamine rush or whatever that makes you
feel like you're accomplishing something
yeah but you're not actually doing
anything yeah yeah well I mean that's
that that's also definitely out there
which is what I think having these rules
about how you use things instead of just
the the snow is actually usually pretty
instructive because a lot of times
you'll use the general idea that this
technology could be useful to me uh-huh
as the excuse that allows it to become
this constant companion this thing that
you're always using like for example
roughly speaking of the people who
reported back to me from the de-clutter
experiment I would say 50% of them kept
some social media in their life and 50%
essentially got rid of all of it when
they went through the exercise of what
am i value 50% had some values to it
social media served but of those 50% it
was like 90 plus percent took it off
their phone because when they actually
went through well what is the value I
get out of this particular social media
platform that's really important to me
almost never did that value require them
to check it a hundred times a day
yeah and so this was a really common
thing among the minimalist who use
social media is that they don't they
don't have it on their phone and that
alone gets rid of sort of like 99% of
the of the cost yeah because the
experience on a desktop or a laptop is
is just inherently different yeah and
they put the money when it came to the
compulsive use they put the money in the
mobile mhm
that was the bet they made around
2011-2012 is that this thing is with
people all the time and so we need to
make this addictive because it's with
people all the time and get a lot of
eyeballs it was a little bit less useful
for them to make right the desktop
versions as addictive one of the things
that I use on my laptop when I want to
write is this program called freedom
yeah but this yeah it basically turns
off the internet it's impossible get
online for a preset time yeah but still
that's like a band-aid you know that's
not really addressing the underlying
like if you can solve that underlying
need and drive by doing the things that
you're talking about then the need for
something like freedom will be less
acute I think that's true so freedom
what I found there's a lot of people use
it as like a training tool you use it
for maybe a month at a time right
can you essentially trying to lose the
taste so where people use it very
successfully I think is for train
themselves out of the web surfing habit
is that's one of these things where well
it's just there right I'm on my computer
got 40 tabs open yeah you have the
browser later yeah you can't it's like
social maybe you don't use Facebook
right you can like not use an app at the
web the web is always there and we build
these web surfing habits where you go
through the the cycle of the 20 sites
you always look at us right like that so
a lot of freedom for example you go
let's say a month of you actually block
those sites while you're working you
can't do the cycle you find after a
month you know more often than not that
you turn off the the freedom blocking
and you've lost a taste to have to do
that right I mean I went through the
similar exercise real early on in sort
of my working career where I found that
I had this web surfing cycle and I sort
of trained myself out of web surfing and
now I don't know how to web surf which
is a huge boon actually if you don't
have a stable of sites the that you go
through like I just go here I go here I
go here I go here if you lose that taste
it's it's like a huge boon to your
project yeah yeah have you noticed a
difference between somebody who is you
know living a life more as a manager of
people versus somebody who is
more creative type somebody who's
creating content producing you know
things that come out of deep work
because Bryan Holaday talks about this a
lot he wrote a blog post about the
difference between managers and makers
somebody who's a manager there in a
generally in a corporate culture there's
a lot of people involved in things like
you know slack and email like and
meetings that's their whole day is like
moving pieces around the board and
that's productive in the construct of
what they do and how they kind of
advance within their own world versus
somebody's writing a book or you know
people who really need to kind of engage
with solitude in a fundamentally
different way well I guess two things
going on so one we have moved more of
that managerial work into the work cycle
of the creatives and so this is
something that there's an economist
named Peter Sassoon who wrote this this
paper back in the early 90s when the
personal computer was really becoming
you know well used in the office place
and and he had this effect he documented
called the diminishment of intellectual
specialization well what's happening is
is that networked computers made it
possible there's a lot of administrative
type of managerial tasks that used to be
hard enough that you had to have
dedicated people to do them they became
easy enough that now like in theory
anyone could do them and so we began to
merge roles so now even the typical you
know creative worker someone who does
high-level cognitive work
there's doing tons of administrative and
managerial type of activities all the
time they're interacting with HR and
this and that and on these committees
and and and we've merged those two
worlds and so I think one thing that we
have to do is resep rate that much more
clearly right now they're two merged
everyone's just sort of in this general
pool of we have inboxes and answer
things but to I think the way that a lot
of managing happening happens today is
itself probably very ineffective and so
a lot of managering today is the sort of
hyperactive hive mind let's just keep
this unstructured conversation going
right and we're trying to talk here talk
here talk there what's going on here and
connect this to that but in an age
before email there's a lot more
structure to what it meant to manage
right and so I think that's also also
problematic we've gone down to this sort
of least common denominator or Pro
managing words let's just kind of keep
everyone talking if I can reach you at
any time you can reach me at any time we
can have this ongoing unstructured
conversation just try to figure things
out on the fly and so yeah if you're a
manager using that approach to work you
have to constantly be connected because
if you're not servicing these
conversations the whole thing falls
apart yeah the wheels grind to a halt
but something I've been arguing I'm
working on new book about this is that
that's not necessarily the only way to
do this right we could be more
structured I mean I think there's a lot
of innovation that happen in
understanding I call it a tension
capital theory understanding the best
way to sort of hire a bunch of minds and
get value out of it we're we're in the
early stages of this and and what we're
doing now it's like the primitive
factories in the early Industrial Age
before we really figure it out how do
you actually use industrial capital to
build things efficiently we're in the
early stages I think yeah ss my claim
now I heard you say that if you were
running Google that you would just make
sure that anyone who's programming is
completely there
you cannot contact these people like you
were no email a lot of money yeah to
like do what they do like leave them
alone like let them do what they do but
if you're bugging them every five
minutes then you're not getting the
value out of them that you could be
getting yeah to me it's crazy if I ran
Google and I'm paying whatever five or
six hundred thousand for a 10x
programmer I don't have an email address
right Oh Oh higher so o hire someone
that you like a 22 year old amazonian by
faraday cage yeah with their team right
so they can collaborate I'll hire a 22
year old the the they have 19 screens
open and do everything a half but yeah I
have an article in the in the latest
Chronicle of Higher Education where I'm
basically making this claim about
professors and I say this is crazy
the they titled it is email making
professor stupid they say that the whole
point of this profession is to sort of
think deeply and really well and and all
we do is email and it's like but there's
no reason for this university is not a
really competitive business is very
stable we can experiment we'll be okay I
think higher education there's a point
of this article higher education should
take the lead and radically reforming
our how we work so that professors
essentially spend like most of their
time actually right thinking and trying
to teach the best classes and produce
original research but now we all have to
go on
and Dave of asana silent meditation
retreats to get that yeah okay but then
we come back then we come back we self
to answer the email free car right and
go into the intranet the the enter our
expense receipts and you know yeah I
just don't think we have this we don't
have this figured out yet and I think
there's gonna be a first mover advantage
I think it's going to come out of
Silicon Valley this is where a lot of
innovation is happening in workflows
it's in software development because yes
it's it's digital and on a screen but
it's pretty close to an industrial
metaphor because you're producing a
product and they're really starting to
experiment now with like agile
methodologies like scrum and you see
things like Kanban where they're trying
to get creative about how do we actually
structure work how do we communicate
with each other where our tasks actually
track as opposed to just we're all in
our inboxes are all just talking to each
other and I think when the first Google
comes along and says our programmers
don't have email addresses anymore and
they make whatever 2x more revenue this
is going to be the stiffing right where
everyone is gonna everyone I can see it
I can see that happening I mean we we
were talking before the podcast two days
ago I was up at Jack Dorsey's house in
San Francisco I had him on the podcast
and it was a super interesting
experience for a lot of reasons not the
least of which was just getting a
glimpse like being in his home and
spending several hours with him getting
a glimpse on how this guy who's the CEO
of two of the biggest companies in
Silicon Valley actually lives his life
on a daily basis and I was struck with
the extent to which that lifestyle is
driven by purpose and value that
correlates directly with minimalism I
mean his house is oriented around I'm a
very sparse stoic streamlined
minimalistic lifestyle the guy meditates
at least an hour every day an hour every
morning he's eliminated distractions he
works two days a week from his home
where he literally sits at his kitchen
counter overlooking the ocean like oh
look I mean he said his kitchen counter
the way a lot of people do you know he
could be living extravagantly but he's
really not you know I got a glimpse of
it and just the the grounded
very intentional way that he
communicated to me about how he makes
decisions about how his time is
allocated was profound I think and I
think it's what allows him to have the
equanimity and the composure to be able
to manage everything that's coming at
him every single day and I can't help
but think that that will at some point
that that methodology that philosophy
that perspective will find its way
downstream into the way that these
companies are crafted from the ground up
to create more efficient work systems
that are oriented around getting the
best out of people in the most holistic
way I think you're right
I mean really the the main issue is
convenience but this is always the this
is always the tail when you look at
innovation and how we do commerce in
different technological periods is
usually to push back is against
convenience right so the assembly line
was an incredibly inconvenient way to
run a factory it's a giant pain yeah you
got to spend more money there's all
these hard edges now like we don't get
this just right this piece is gonna pile
up at this piece and now we need more
managers we have to put in all this new
technology right it's like it's a it's a
huge pain but it produce cars you know
two necks faster it's going to be
similar if we try to restructure
knowledge work to focus on getting a
return on attention capital so to focus
on people producing value with their
brains in a sustainable way it's going
to generate tons of inconveniences right
because I can't now just reach you it's
incredibly convenient if I can just
reach you and we don't have to think
about structure and channels and I spent
some time recently going back and
learning about the structure they use in
the Apollo program right so how did we
send the man to the moon without email
and I got into like how they actually
did this right I mean it was all these
teams all around the country like
billions of dollars and how did they
actually coordinated intend emails back
right it's a it's a huge pain right
after these interfaces and protocols but
it worked and so that's what we're up
against now so the reason why a lot of
these efforts have failed is if you're
not jack dorsey if you're not at the
very top what you're doing is going to
make life inconvenient for someone above
you probably make life inconvenient for
some people at your level is
and so how do we overcome that it's like
a chicken in the egg problem and I think
that's why we're at this stalemate where
people increasingly recognize this is
not the right way to work but no one can
really take the first step because you
know making the jump from the old way
you build cars to the assembly line it
sort of required a Henry Ford to say you
know you know what the hell let's just
do it
because I said so and it could be a huge
pain and I don't care right and so the
next book is world without email yeah
right and so what it what does that look
like well I mean that's that's the basic
idea is moving past this sort of generic
hyperactive hivemind workflow which is
we're all just in conversation all day
long unstructured and actually figure
out a workflow that makes sense for your
business and so you think about the main
capital resource and knowledge work as
being human brains and so like in any
sort of capital industry how do we get
the best return on that capital well now
you have to really care about things
like context switching now you have to
care about sustainability I mean you
really do burn the people out pretty
fast when they have to do these second
shifts at night and trying to catch up
on all their email or this or that and
so I'm still early in the the research
for the book but basically I'm arguing
that this bet we made that just making
communication faster and more flexible
was gonna make us all more productive
turned out to be a failed bet and so now
it's time to try something else so I
foresee in the future I'm not quite sure
what I'll look like but I think we're
gonna have much more specialization much
more specialization of roles much more
sort of structured and bespoke systems
for how information moves in between
places much more respect for psychology
so how does a brain stay happy how does
a brain produce a lot of value and so
we're gonna see a lot of these type of
properties a lot more of a separation I
think from cognitive reduction and
administration I mean there's a lot of
different ideas we're going to see but
hopefully what we're not going to see
it's just a generic inbox it has a
thousand emails and that your main work
activity is just trying to turn through
the Inbox
right well I also think I can't help but
think that that the maturation of AI is
gonna play a huge role and how we
navigate all of that as well well some
of these these human cognitive skills
can be you know offloaded
- well that's super that's the in reims
yeah I mean that's the end of them but
it's actually known as the endgame
there's a lot of money being invested
right now in doing exactly this is can
we essentially have AI play the role
that like Leo McGarry played for you
know president Bartlet in the West Wing
like a chief of staff like that manages
all the communication for you manages
you know all the passing back and forth
information it can just tell you like
richly you should be working on today
I've gathered all the things you need
I'll get it to the person who needs it
when you're done but this is going to be
the sort of good news bad news thing
right
a lot of money's been being put into
doing this let's say we succeed and now
all creative workers have essentially an
AI chief of staff that talks to each
other's AI chief of staff now as a
creative worker mainly what you're going
to do is think hard it'll take care of
everything else they'll just that's what
you should be working on I've got it all
here for you that sounds like good news
right I mean you don't have to do email
all day but because we're doing email
all day it's gonna make you much much
more effective and so now if I'm running
a company I'm thinking I don't need 12
people right only 12 at copywriters
anymore six will do it because they're
not spending their time doing email a
day or I don't need this many lawyers
this one you can get the same amount of
work done I don't need these many
programmers because with AI offloading
all the context switching they're much
more effective so it's possible that the
the creative class that feels like
they're immune from AI because what they
do directly can't be automated it's not
as immune as they think because if the
AI can take out all of the other stuff
that's making us really inefficient
we're not gonna need as many of us
anymore yeah that's something that
evolve talks a lot about yeah well I
mean I think we're that that that that
dawn is coming
yeah and things are gonna get messy and
interesting yeah so either it's gonna be
terrible like we're gonna need a lot
less creative workers or we'll have some
sort of creative destruction and figure
out many more domains to use high-level
creative I mean we'll see
but yeah it's gonna be disruptive so
talk me through your own information and
technology diet you know somebody who's
written all these books and somebody who
you know is in computer science teaches
computer science is also blogging like
you're not completely offline so
how do you get your news and your
information what does that diet look
like so I have no social media I read a
paper newspaper every morning
The Washington Post gets delivered to my
doorstep such an old man I am an old man
ha ha I know I'd be good hundred fifty
years ago it'd be great it's right small
town lawyer or something Ryan holiday
should have you're both born out of time
yeah but he actually he bought the ranch
so he's a step ahead of me yeah yeah I'm
not shooting boar off my back board
you're taking long walks and to come
apart yeah yeah yeah right it's like
Ryan holiday without the boar
without killing the boars yeah so I get
my news of the world primarily from the
newspaper which I actually like because
the articles aren't algorithmically
selected for me so I end up reading
things I want it normally of clicked on
so you sort of learn about interesting
world and local events I read a lot of
books it's sort of part of what I need
to do for my job is that I'm just
constantly reading books and then and
this maybe is unfair because it's not
generally replicatable but I have this
email address called interesting at Cal
Newport calm because I have these great
readers I've been blogging for over a
decade I'm a huge blogging fan there's
there's a lot of reasons why I think
this was probably the way to do the
social internet not these big platforms
so I have these critters ship and
incredibly smart and really has their
finger on what's going on and so this
address is say well if there's like an
article online or something I really
should know about send it to this
address and so it's kind of not fair
because that's not generally
replicatable but this is where I often
come across you know interesting things
that are going on relevant to my work is
that my readers will send it to me like
oh you got to see this article in The
New York Times or so that it's sort of
like my own ad hoc social media yeah
you've just created your own social
network yeah except where it's not
attention engineered so I can't look at
it 150 times a day but also a lot of the
other tips I get about what I should be
reading or what I should be doing comes
from the old-fashioned type of social
networking which is you know I have good
friends especially in the industry like
other writers and stuff I know about it
we talk and we get together and they say
should read this have you heard about
this and and and so it's just old fast
in social networking yeah and that seems
to work I mainly don't web surf I don't
entertain myself online very much I've
no bookmarks when I work I am very
scheduled so when I work I'm very
intense like I'm doing the
right now as intensely as possible and
when I'm done working I'm done working
so I don't really have idle time for you
know I don't have time to fill with sort
of when you are working especially in
the research phase of putting these
books together I would imagine you have
to have some tabs open because you're
researching things and you're trying to
find out information about this and that
it can't all be in print books yeah
right so so I do get useful leads I do
do some internetting to find articles
often I really separate them it's like
I'm this trip to California for example
I have a folder on my computer full of
PDFs and they're all stories on latest
psych research on social medias in fact
on positive well-being because I'm
writing this article right where I need
to know these things and so I had a
gathering step where I gathered all of
that and now I have these articles with
me and you know I was reading them on
the plane and so the processing I see
which is something that in academia is
very normal like so in academia if
you're doing academic research
especially in like math like I do the
typical structure is you sort of you
find the articles you print them then
you have the articles with you uh-huh
and then there's this long period of
sort of tangling with the articles and
because it's it's so complicated usually
to figure out math proofs yeah it's a
completely separate activity is trying
to tangle with a printed article and
figure it out and so that separation is
very clear to me there's gathering stuff
then a completely separate activity is
trying to make sense of it and what kind
of phone do you have so I've got a new
one
so I had my wife's old iPhone and then
it started clicking on its own which I
discovered when I'd be in uber and it
would just change the route with while
the still in my pocket so I don't know I
just I don't know what number it is so
you have an iPhone I don't have a
certain number of apps on there but just
no social media apps yeah yeah so for
example you had you took an uber out to
my house long drive like what did you do
in the car like were you looking at your
phone no I talked to Oscar did you yeah
fascinating I learned we learned a lot I
learned about his daughter
I learned about was so engrossing that
he took some wrong turns right we missed
a couple exercises he didn't seem to
notice I notice because hey we got here
huh
yeah it's well I the phone so if you
take off the apps in which someone makes
money every time you tap on it it really
does put the phone back into that
original jobs II envision which is this
beautiful tool that you take out to do
certain things and it does it really
really well like you can call an uber
you can look up a map you can you know
look up a movie time like maybe I want
to go to this movie theater or something
like this or if you're meeting someone
like I can text them like yeah I'm
around the corner like it's great for
that but it's such a different
relationship because it's not the
constant companion model right let's
talk about parenting we both have young
kids how do you think about and talk
about how we should effectively parent
our children around these devices I'm
trying to figure it out so my oldest is
six so it's like we're not you're not
quite at that urgent right stage of
relevance but I've been looking into a
lot talking to a lot of parents who are
to try to find out and a couple things
I'm noticing is one there really does
seem to be an issue especially with
adolescents and oh it's huge huge
massive and there's this weird kind of
tit-for-tat thing going on in the
research literature and the psych
research literature where someone will
publish something that says this is
negative and then someone else because
it's all about pushing back on trends
and will say no no you're looking at the
numbers wrong it's not so negative you
talk to any parent and there seems to be
no no confusion like yes it's not
debatable yeah but it's tricky yeah you
know I can't tell my 15 year old
daughter that she can't use her phone
and even to the extent that I want a
police behavior around that it becomes
very you know
tricky yeah well you have the bad luck
of timing because this is new and so my
conjecture is culture is going to change
on this I think so I mean I have two
boys that are 22 and 23 and I would
almost put them in the in the
neo-luddite camp like they don't they're
really analog like they they're not
interested I mean they have Instagram
accounts they almost never post
don't look at it yeah it's they don't
you know if I text them it takes forever
for them to text me like there does not
yeah online and then I look at my two
daughters completely different picture
yeah well but that they're right in the
sweet spot from like a timing
perspective a cultural timing
perspective we're sort of at the height
of teenage especially teenage girls
social media age girls I mean this is
this is if their vernacular this is the
vocabulary this is you know the a
fifteen-year-old girl the most important
thing in her life is her is her social
yes life that's not gonna change and if
you the phone is it the vortex of all of
that yeah this is how they communicate
yeah and so it's not a simple matter of
like okay you know phone between this
time and this time no I think so so the
way I think the culture is going to
change is I think the idea that
adolescents use these sort of highly
appealing social media applications I
think that's going to change
I think move towards maybe simpler
phones I think that might change as well
because we have we have two things
happening right now we have the the
health research that's saying the
starting to get scary even though there
is some debate on it there's some pretty
scary numbers on what happens once you
get widespread social mental mental
well-being you mean mental well-being
and the corresponding hospitalizations
for self-harm and suicide attempts goes
right up yeah with it but to I'm picking
up on them on the road from parents
talking about there's this growing
emergent resistance from the teenagers
themselves that they're starting to get
just like people of our age and older
are starting to get tired of how much
looking at the phone the teenagers are
not happy about having to maintain their
snapchat streaks or whatever it is it
seems like work it's it's they know too
that it's a problem and and so what I
think Jonathan hight the psychologist
Jonathan hight has this sort of this
great idea which is because he really
cares about this as well he's been on
the road talking about this and what
he's saying is we don't need to convince
let's say everyone in your daughter's
class to stop using social media and
smartphone before it's palatable for her
what you need is like three people the
cool people it's positive deviator right
or it just it makes it a possibility
like some people don't do it now that
makes it a legitimate option then you
don't have to do it your
would it be the only one not to do it
and so his take which I find optimistic
is getting from everyone does this -
there's three people who don't is not a
huge gap but that's pretty much the gap
you have to jump that gives cover -
people say young people who are really
unhappy about what's going on on here
and so anyways that's what I'm hoping if
if my kids were just coming to that age
right now I think it would be hard I
mean I think I would be really - the
work I've done on this I'd be really
reluctant to let them have a smartphone
yeah it's deeply concerning yeah the
trains already pulled out of the station
and in our house you know and and there
are times where I feel powerless like I
really just don't know what the right
thing to do or say is yeah well and it's
also arbitrary that's I mean the the
actual sort of activities on some of
these apps is so oddly contrived like
with these streaks and these pictures
and you tap on these things and it's
attention engineered the whole thing
just feels a little bit yeah yeah sort
of unsavory I know man but you're
optimistic because I'm sensing this
groundswell I don't know yeah in GQ
magazine I said that you know we were
gonna look back in ten years at giving a
and whatever a teenager a smartphone
might be would give me a teenager in
fact of cigarettes and that got me miss
in trouble did it yeah I read that
article was a very long article and it
was pretty straight free point-blank
straightforward yeah point yeah so so I
know it's more complicated but I've
decided the role I'm gonna play is I'll
advocate for the one of the extremes
yeah but when you contextualize that
against you know kind of how you talk
about the progression of these
technologies over time in the book
starting with Samuel Morse and Morse
code and you know these the Gestalt of
these things is constant forward
progression and acceleration without
ever taking that moment that beat to say
why are we doing this or how is this
serving us and that's the human
condition and the constant forward
momentum picture is a little bit it's
more complicated than that right because
actually it's this bifurcations we try
all these things and some of them keep
moving on and some of these bifurcations
are dead ends and so like a lot of the
work I do is trying to separate let's
say large social media platforms from
the social Internet project in general
and so it's completely reasonable to
think about a lot of these social media
platforms is just being a fork right
that's kind of a dead end right a lot of
the different things messy things that
we're trying we have internet and people
trying to figure out the right way to
use the Internet we're gonna try a lot
of things and the idea that you know
five years from now we don't use
snapchat anymore doesn't necessarily
represent you know in into forward
progress it could actually be completely
consistent with a narrative of forward
progress as part of progress in
technology is to sort of evolution and
experimentation to try to understand you
know think about the first calm boom
right in the late 90s it was about okay
the internet should all be about
e-commerce that's what the Internet is
going to be it's everyone's gonna have a
store and everyone can sell to everyone
it's gonna unlock and it didn't work
right it turned out that we only need
one store Amazon and so this wasn't
gonna fuel the economy and so we try it
again like well maybe the Internet's all
gonna be about social and like that's
what's going on now it's not about the
first dot-com crash was not about I
guess and into the forward progress the
internet I think it's part of this sort
of more when you're in the moment it's
much more messy and so that's why I
think we have to keep critically engaged
like well what are we doing with this
tech do I really need to be doing this
what could be better is blogging better
than Facebook maybe fit you know these
type of questions
I think locally might seem like tech vs.
Luddite or something like that
but it's actually a big part of the
process of actually trying to evolve how
we use tech in our culture well you can
telescope up from technology in general
I mean technology is what is consuming
our focus and our attention at the
moment but really you know ultimately
fundamentally what you're talking about
is living an intentional life versus
living a reactive life yeah and
technology is the template upon which
you're you know explaining these things
but it does go back to you has stoic
philosophy in certain respects like what
does it mean to live a meaningful life
and we always have to keep coming back
to this question and there's all sorts
of cultural forces that require us to
come back to this question and so yeah
right now I think you're right to point
out that like right now technology is
one of the things that's making us
having to re-examine this question yeah
just like we had in this sort of the 80s
and 90s maybe heightened consumerism had
to make us think about this question the
secularization of Western culture has
forced a lot of people in the last
hundred years
do we think about this question is all
sorts of forces that keep bringing us
back to this fundamental question right
and and to kind of tie it to you know
the book that preceded this deep work
this idea that that the deep work is
what gives our life meaning yeah right
so can we let's talk about that a little
bit yeah I mean I ended on that quote
that something like the deep life is a
good life mm-hmm
which was a more there's more general
observation I mean one of the things
that was interesting about that book is
that it was supposed to all be just
professional productivity right that's
what this is about and I ended up adding
this chapter about you know deep work is
meaningful because I kept running into
all these different sources that were
from all sorts of different disciplines
that all were making the same argument
that focusing intensely on something
that's really valuable is a huge source
of of satisfactions a huge source of
meaning and when you get away from that
you lose that satisfaction and meaning
and so even though that book was
supposed to be a business book I
couldn't help having this chapter in
there I was talking about philosophers
and we're really understanding you know
the value it got a little bit head in
the clouds when I was talking about the
value the wheel right yeah the wheel
right who understands the intrinsic
properties of the wood and that's like
no ESS on this system of values that's
that's cited outside of himself I mean
what makes what good or not good is not
his own decision it's it's a part of it
and then that in that you actually get
this you know found that since a mean
iam it can get pretty heady but all
pursuit of mastery fast right yeah it's
like hero Dreams of Sushi you know like
somebody who devotes their life in
pursuit of mastering a certain thing
there's inherent value and meaning and
and and that will like drive your life
forward with purpose yeah yeah and can
and can help you make decisions about
well I don't use this and I don't answer
email or whatever it is and you can do
that with complete confidence because
you know another you don't need busyness
for example they try to convince
yourself that you're doing something
meaningful because you're making the
sushi and you know you know that's
what's meaningful I mean in deep work I
spent some time with a blacksmith that
makes swords it's like what about if the
question was what about this resonates
like I have no interest in making swords
like I'm not gonna live he has this
open-air barn I'm you
the Great Lakes where he sits in there
his name's Rick fur and hammers on these
things and he's a specialist in ancient
methods so like he really understands
ancient steel and how to make swords and
I watched this documentary about him and
the question is like why does this
resonate with everyone and it's it's
mastery right like he does this thing
and he does it really well and you can
watch him do it and his whole life is
focused on you know what at the moment
like focused on this thing that he finds
really important yeah and I think we've
lost our connection with just how
important that is and I think that's a
big reason why free solo was such a big
deal this tell you what did you see his
documentary I haven't seen it yet but
I've written some about Alex yeah so
alex is a master and and that
documentary at its core was really about
a master in pursuit of mastery you know
in in the most fundamental traditional
way and in a very tactile way in which
the stakes could not be higher yeah and
I really believe that the movie is
gripping not just because he's hanging
on by fingernail on this wall but
because you're seeing somebody in real
time pursue something with such pure you
know intentionality and a purpose and
it's become a rarity and what's
interesting about alex is that for
something like a month before his major
climbs he stops using social media yeah
because he's eliminated all distractions
he's living incredibly minimally and
intentionally there's nothing in his
life or in his van that doesn't serve
the purpose that he seeks from his
existence yeah but so that's pushing
this idea to an extreme but I think
there's a core idea there that's so
fundamental which is doing something
that's that's hard and that you find
meaningful is like a huge source of
satisfaction and that these other things
that busyness things does things that
push us towards our screens all the time
are in contrast to it it gets in the way
of it I mean he's okay
the fact that he's not on Facebook for
this month before I ever I don't think
he worries about it for know and I think
yeah I think he would be you know a good
example of a digital minimalist because
he is on social media he's on Instagram
and he shares but he does it in a
healthy appropriate way yeah so I love
these stories I'm
so I've written that Chronicle Higher
Education article is telling you about
it opens on this sort of emeritus
professor at Stanford who's right he's
been writing since the 60s the sort of
definitive series it's called the art of
computer programming he basically
invented all the big ideas or four
algorithm theory but he got rid of email
in the 90s he said I'd used it for 20
years and I think I've done enough and
so he has this set up where he has this
assistant he got weight so he'd been
using it for tweet he'd been using the
early internet I am using for 20 years
when everybody else is first discovering
anything over it he's over it in 1992
he'd use it for 20 years and so so he he
says this is what I care about is this
great quote he's like for some people
their goal is to be on top of things for
me I think my goal like wearing most
sort of the world's be on the bottom of
things and so this is what I'm doing I'm
working on my books and if you need to
contact me here's my mailing address at
Stanford it goes to his assistant who
goes through it all prints it out and
once every two to three months they sit
down and they go through the things that
have been that have been mailed through
and it frustrates everyone like he says
on his website please stop emailing
other professors in this department and
trying to get them to think I will get
very mad I'm not gonna have you don't
bother them to do that and so yeah sure
he's missing out on opportunities and
connections at this and that but like
that's his his solo El Capitan is this
book series and like I'm glad he's doing
that yeah and world is better with him
doing that than fielding email yeah or
Neal Stephenson my other example the
novelist write the science fiction
writer who I really enjoy his work he
has this great famous essay called why
I'm a bad correspondent and he was
saying I know you know I'm a sci-fi
writer so I have I know you're my fans
and you really want to interact with me
he's like if I do that like if I'm doing
emails or this or that what do I end up
with I have a lot of these interactions
that are only relevant to the people I'm
talking to so maybe like in two years I
talked to a thousand people but if I
instead put that attention on writing a
book I could have a book that a hundred
thousand people are gonna readings gonna
last for decades and decades and so like
I think that's a better use of my time
is focusing on doing one thing that's
really important as opposed to all these
small things that have a little bit of
value so I love these examples and I
think there should be more of this
there's something inherently terrifying
about making yourself difficult to reach
at least that's what I feel like that's
what comes
for me when I start to think about what
that would be like if I was to take that
leap you are and I don't know what what
from where that comes from you know what
is that about well one of the things
I've discovered I mean I'm pretty hard
to reach is people don't get as mad as
you would think it seems to me that
clarity is more important than
accessibility so what upsets people is
if they're not sure whether or not they
can get in touch with you and they're
not sure if you're gonna respond or not
but I have this sort of I call it a
cinder filter which is now a thing right
it's like okay here's the different
reasons you can send messages to these
addresses for these reasons and here's
what to expect like if you send things
to this like don't expect for me to
respond people don't actually get that
map because they have clarity they're
like great I know I have clear
expectations like I know I can teach Cal
for these type of things I know some
people are entitled to connect with you
yeah but they don't people don't get as
mad as you would think if it's clear if
it's like you know no Neal Stephenson's
like I I want to write books like I'm
sorry I can't reach me and you're like
ah that's frustrating the moment but you
know people aren't mad at him about it
if on the other hand like you are kind
of accessible but you sometimes answer
and you sometimes don't and you like
well why didn't you get back to that's
where that's where I'm at and it's
created a friend of mine says rich you
have you have you're in a constant state
of freeform free-flowing overwhelm yeah
you know it's like my persistence gauge
that is exactly true and and I have a
very haphazard relationship with how I
manage like what's coming in like
sometimes I'll respond and sometimes I
don't
yeah sometimes I stare at that email
inbox and I'm just like I just can't
just forget it man I feel like deleting
the whole thing yeah then I'm like then
I'll sit down and respond for hours and
hours and hours on another day yeah I'm
still trying to figure it you know what
I'm doing now is so in non-fiction
writing like there's a lot of people
that no longer manage their own inboxes
yeah and so I've been gathering some
curious I've been I've been gathering
stories a lot of people are doing that
yeah I hire virtual assistants to do
that yeah we're just real assistants I
think you know it's not cheap yeah but
but I've seen and I'm curious so now
I've been interviewing people just for
my own edification like what's how does
this work logistically but I'm seeing
that more where it's basically just
you know eventually you have to wipe
your hands clean yeah but there is
something inherently flawed about having
to hire another human being to deal with
a technology platform yeah on
communication that doesn't seem
efficient yeah your your computer first
and right like hasn't that seemed flawed
yeah well maybe what that's a
recognition of is like in nonfiction
writing now if you're writing a certain
type of book I guess you're like a mini
business yeah and like any type of mini
business it's just going to have a begin
flow and eventually someone needs to
manage it but yeah I agree like
fundamentally yeah if you have to if you
have to hire I mean I wrote I wrote a
piece about this long time ago this
article right i contrasted two different
entrepreneurs and they both had the
email overload problem and i guess the
one entrepreneur hired an assistant and
trained them up and wrote this really
long article about like incredibly
complicated system of how they did it
and got to them the things they needed
to respond to and the other entrepreneur
said I don't have any I don't do email
it so kind of like an easy answer to the
same problem and they both ended up oh
they're both doing fine they both were
running sort of web-based brands like
podcast plus blogs like write and
writing the type of work that sort of
we're talking about here yeah one guy
said you know what here's my mailing
address and the other guy has this
incredibly highly trained assistant and
this sort of twenty page no instruction
man how to deal with it and you know
what like they're both doing fine and
probably the cheaper option was was
option a so maybe we'll see more of that
as well I mean I basically do that I
don't have a general-purpose public
email address mm-hmm I think there is no
just like I want to hear from you here's
my address I'm not on social media like
there's really no way there's really no
it's very hard to get in touch with me
yeah normally yeah you can send me
things which I appreciate like people
send me links and stuff which I
appreciate because I look at them but
it's very clear like I'm not gonna
answer
uh-huh and then that's kind of it right
like if I have a book launch I you know
my publicist is available for you know
you can contact my publicist and for
speaking there's a speaking agent right
you have people that are fielding like
my whole thing would be that I'm missing
out on opportunities yeah maybe you are
maybe you are no I guess if somebody if
it's if you
if it's a real thing and it's important
enough somebody will figure out how to
get in touch with you I did have that
happen recently I did you found out
later like yeah so I got is cool thing
well I did something for CBS for CBS
this morning around this book because
for this book there was like here's a
public they could there's a publicist
under stick in contact but the producer
was like you know I'd read this thing of
yours like a couple years ago and I was
like oh that's great we should get him
on we should get him on the show he's
like I didn't know how to get in touch
with you right and so I was like
whatever and then now when this came up
like he had a way to do it so yeah that
happened it requires some trust right
and yeah and a healthy relationship with
FOMO but that's see that's maximalism
though so if we go back to the the
minimalism axle ISM sort of dichotomy
like maximalism is about not missing out
on value right I'm gonna spend hours and
hours and hours scrolling so I don't
miss you so that there one that one
thing yeah you know that's maximalism
right because maximalism says if I if
I'm missing out on something valuable
it's almost like someone took that value
from me it's like someone took that out
of my pond you know and I don't want to
lose things minimalism says well I
already know for sure that you know my
books are really impactful and working
really hard on this book is going to
make a big difference and they're you
know for sure that like I do these
articles and these are really and so I'm
gonna put all my energy there and so
minimalism would say what you get from
missing out on some of those
opportunities is that you're able to put
more energy on the things that are more
valuable but because those give you such
a high return you know that energy is
going to give you a high return you end
up better off right as long as you
really are taking that time to do the
deep work and you're not becoming a
dilettante which is why I'm not on
social yeah because I don't trust myself
get rid of the temptations alright well
let's let's round this out with with
maybe some practical takeaways for for
people so if somebody's listening to
this and they're like okay I'm inspired
I'm gonna I'm gonna pick up the book I'm
gonna check it out like what are some
things that I could do today though that
might improve the quality of my
existence like some simple things that
yeah are easily implementable so if
you're if you're contemplating making
the shift of digital minimalism there's
there some things you can do to kind of
get in shape before you consider the big
30 day transformation so three things
one take off your phone
anything where someone makes money every
time you tap on it so you don't have to
quit anything
you're not losing access to anything but
you just can't have it as a default
thing on your phone you have to go to
your doesn't somebody make money off
anything that's on your phone now well
okay where someone makes money off your
attention every time that screen is open
so basically like social media online
news feeds you no take that off your
phone that alone is going to make a big
difference to introduce solitude back
into your life so just try once a day to
do something where you don't have your
phone with you or the phone is with you
but in a mode where you know it's in the
bottom of your bag and do not disturb or
something like this
so just your brain starts to get a
little bit of breathing room 3 start
aggressively reinvestigating the type of
high quality analog leisure activity is
that whenever or grandfather's in
cressid do when they had downtime start
introducing that back into your life
just getting a taste again for these
sort of higher startup costs type
activities that give you more meaning
all of that gets you in shape so that if
and when you decide to do the big 30-day
marathon it's gonna be a lot less
terrifying right that's pretty good
advice yeah
do you listen to audiobooks or podcasts
yeah you do
yeah I like podcast yeah yeah you're
doing for a long time yeah cool man I
really enjoyed this yeah thank you
thanks you are doing the deep work this
is uh I really think that that this
issue is is really the epidemic of our
time you know I mean we have a lot of
problems culturally right now but I
think we're only gonna see the
maturation you know the long-term impact
of our relationship with these mobile
devices and technology in general is
going to continue to manifest in
malignant ways so I really appreciate
you being you know the sound of reason
and and caution in the context of this
conversation and I think we're gonna see
more and more people speaking out about
this and hopefully innovating new ways
healthier ways through all of this
because technology is certainly not
going away yeah yeah I mean we need
philosophies and so digital minimalism
is one but yeah I think that would be
the bigger legacy is not that if
becomes a digital minimalist but that
other people start thinking if not that
then what right we need we need we need
a Manhattan Project around this I think
yeah I don't know if anything like that
is going on like where's the Council of
digital minimalist getting together it's
a you know debate the future of
technology but I certainly see wisdom in
compiling just such a group of people
yeah well good get on that I'm working
on all right good yeah well Tristan
Harris of course he's got he's got a
non-profit they're doing this yeah
they're working on this yeah yeah cool
all right man so thank you so much pick
up the book digital minimalism if you
want to connect with Cal you can't
that's impossible to get to me through
rich right you can hit me up and maybe
I'll read it maybe I won't I I'm
impacted by today so I'm really gonna
start looking at ways that I can change
my own behavior around these things yeah
cool great thing right man digital
minimalism deep work all the other books
Cal Newport comm check them out thanks
man yep peace
[Music]